going everybody gets warned and welcome
back to my channel the cosmic wonder
where we talk about all things Marvel
and everything relating to the MCU it's
been over six years since the guardians
of the galaxy vol 1 came out in 2014 the
guardians of the galaxy vol 1 was a very
important movie for the MCU they
introduced the Power Stone and they also
introduced Thanos they also introduced a
very ripped Chris Pratt but I digress
now as most of you know James Gunn
directed guardians of the galaxy vol 1
he also directed guardians number 2 and
he is going to direct guardians of the
galaxy vol 3 and many of you know that
he put hundreds of Easter eggs in all of
his movies and as some of you may know
we have found all of the Easter eggs
from guardians of the galaxy vol 1
except for one it's been six years and
we still haven't discovered all of the
Easter eggs in the film that is until
now possibly a lot of detective work has
been done and it seems like the
community and a couple of youtubers have
figured it out and to top it all off it
does seem like James Gunn has seemingly
confirmed that this is the easter egg or
it's at least extremely close so I'll
break it down step by step and I'll
explain how guardians of the galaxy vol
1 may not be exactly what it seems to be
if you're new be sure to subscribe to
stay up to date on all Marvel and MCU
related news so to start off the one
thing that you have to know for
guardians of the galaxy and for this
Easter Egg is of the music James Gunn
specifically mentioned and most fans
picked up that the music is from
Meredith's point of view and every song
that we hear played in the movie is
played from Peters Walkman or his stereo
so essentially we are listening in on a
conversation between Peter and his
mother and that's really what this final
Easter Egg of the movie comes down to
Peter's mother and just who she really
is now when it comes to guardians volume
1 we visit many different places in the
movie and some of them have coordinates
as when they show where they are now the
YouTuber empty and a discord group
called the guardians egg basket seems to
have figured out what these coordinates
translate to a scene where we see the
dark aster a Kree warship the
coordinates down below seemed to
translate into this is mom's cancer the
high-security prison the kiln seems to
translate into this isn't real
and no we're inside of the celestial
head seems to translate into Meredith
we'll and the group actually tweeted at
James gun revealing their discovery and
James Gunn said that they're about 70
percent correct now these weren't the
only coordinates that were translated
but these are the three that are
believed to be the most accurate and it
ties into the easter-egg of just who
Meredith quill is now in the beginning
of the movie where Peter goes to the
Morag temple to retrieve the power stone
orb we can see that in the background of
this shot as some art on the wall kind
of like ancient Egyptian hieroglyphics
and the art shows four different ancient
figures forging the six Infinity stones
now we don't have to guess on who these
ancient figures are as the production
designers have revealed them they have
identified these figures as death
entropy infinity and eternity now these
ancient figures these beans are all from
Marvel Comics and are all very important
characters in the Marvel Universe
guardians of the galaxy volume 1 was the
first movie to really show thaäôs and
have an interaction with him and in the
comics and the Infinity Gauntlet saga
lady death is actually the main driving
factor of Thanos eliminating half of the
universe with all of the Infinity stones
snapping them away Thanos is absolutely
in love with Lady Death in the comics
and will do anything to get her to fall
in love with him but in this picture
eternity and infinity are opposing death
lady death is an actual cosmic beam that
represents actual death now eternity is
another cosmic entity that actually
represents the Marvel multiverse
now when eternity needs to speak with
humans or other types of life forms you
can actually take a shape of a figure a
still a wet type figure that has the
cosmos inside of him filled with
galaxies and planets now infinity is the
sister of eternity and entropy is the
son of eternity but for the sake of this
Easter Egg we're going to focus on
eternity since eternity shows up again
in guardians of the galaxy volume 2
and this is where the new Easter egg
theory comes in and first and foremost
full credit to new rockstars they're the
ones who came up with this theory and
the theory is that Meredith quill Peter
Quill's mother is actually eternity the
cosmic entity herself if we take a look
at nowhere and we look at the background
all of the different colors of clouds
that are in the background and then we
take a look at the final scene where
Peter is holding the power stone and he
sees his mother and his mother ask him
to take her hand we can see the
background of that looks exactly the
same
also at nowhere when Peter and Gamora
are kind of dancing with each other we
can see that the background is also the
same and let's not forget that the
coordinates for nowhere seem to
translate to Meredith quill now nowhere
as we know is a floating head of a
former celestial God however it is
theorized and widely believed that this
is the head of ego or that it once
contained the brain that would
eventually go on to become ego after all
ego is a celestial and guardians of the
galaxy volume 2 if these are both true
there is a lot of hidden detail between
the scene with Gamora and quill in this
scene they are in the eye of the
celestial which could be ego Peter's
father the camera pans and we all of a
sudden look out into what could be
eternity Peter's mother putting to the
fact that Peter could be the offspring
of two incredibly powerful cosmic beings
now as I mentioned before about eternity
eternity can take a certain type of form
and one of those forms could actually be
the physical body of Peter Quill's
mother Meredith now new rock stars go on
to further explain that Peter quill
could simply be living inside of his
mother's reality since she is eternity
she is the multiverse that he lives in
and that's why Peter Quill's story in
the film is led by the music that his
mother left him this could also explain
why egos so called cancer him infecting
the entire universe could have been
started by him infecting eternity with
the tumor that he put inside of her head
and this could also explain Peters
natural desire to want to save the
universe or guard the galaxy because his
mother is actually eternity this could
also explain why Peters mother nicknamed
him star-lord
you are the light of
my precious son my little star because
that is kind of what he is eternity is
essentially the entire universe filled
with stars and quill is the Sun of all
of that and perhaps this could actually
be where Peter gets his power from and
this leads us to Guardians volume 2
where Peter actually meets his father
ego now at the end of guardians Volume
one
yondu actually downplays ego and his
importance now if we really think about
it why is quill actually different than
all of the other hundreds of kids that
ego had throughout all time ego had
hundreds of different kids and none of
them had the celestial gene and then
while ego is showing Peter eternity ego
says that out of all of his spawns quill
was the only one to carry the connection
to the light not one of them carried the
celestial genes
only you carried the connection to the
light
but why was Peter so different if the
other part of his DNA was simply human
what made him different than any of the
other species that ego mated with and
what gave him that connection to the
so-called light well it could be the
fact that his mother is eternity he
wasn't simply human he was simply birth
by eternity in human form and this could
be why he's so different he's a cross
between two cosmic beings
eternity the embodiment of the Marvel
multiverse and a celestial ego now this
means a couple of different things one
the reason that quill was able to hold
the Power Stone could be because of his
mother and this would actually make
sense because when he's holding the
Power Stone that is when he sees his
mother telling him to reach for his hand
[Music]
and as we notice again the background is
the same background from nowhere where
the coordinates translate to Meredith
quill but this also means that star-lord
is a lot more powerful than we think he
is and he can actually get his powers
back in guardians of the galaxy vol 2
ego dies and as he states when he dies
the power that is inside of quill leaves
quill the power of a celestial that he
got from his father dies with his father
and a lot of people were wondering after
the movie if he's going to be getting
this power back but perhaps what we
could see in the future instead of him
getting the power of his father back he
could actually tap into the power of his
mother eternity after all of Adam
warlock still is coming to destroy the
guardians and Guardians vol 3 Peter is
going to need some help and going to
need a lot more power if he's going to
take on Adam warlock now one of the
coolest parts about this theory for the
final Easter egg that new rock stars
came up with is the fact that they
tweeted at James Gunn about the theory
and James Gunn kind of seemingly
confirmed it
new rock stars tweeted saying guardians
of the galaxy was crafted by James Gunn
with endless details hidden in the
visuals and soundtrack Erik Voss breaks
down the film in our latest Infinity
Saga rewatch including an update on that
infamous still missing easter egg in
which James Gunn retweeted what they
tweeted sane haha amazing work now a lot
of people are considering this to be
somewhat of a confirmation that new rock
stars did in fact find at the final
easter egg a lot of people have tweeted
at James Gunn in the past claiming that
they have found the final Easter egg in
which James Gunn will tweet back sorry
no it's wrong but this time James Gunn
did not deny the fact that they could
have found the final infamous Easter egg
in fact he said amazing work some what
kind of congratulating them for finding
that infamous Easter egg so if this is
true and we have in fact found the final
Easter egg that means that eternity is
actually Peter Quill's mother and she
took on a human form to conceive Peter
quill and now Peter quill exists inside
of his mother's reality what does
everybody think about this this is
seemingly the easter egg that has been
missing for all this time let me know
what you think in the comments down
below another shout out to new rock
stars for coming up with this theory and
probably finding that infamous easter
egg don't forget to like this video and
subscribe
notifications turned on so you can stay
up to date on all things relating to
Marvel and at the MCU you can follow me
on Twitter for live updates and as
always thank you all so much for
watching woof woof